Ça y est, les J.O démarrent dans quelques jours
et je suis dans les starting blocks
et même dans une forme olympique,
il faut dire que ça fait un an
qu'on les attend, ces J.O.
Et j'ai bien cru qu'ils ne verraient jamais le jour.
C'est déjà arrivé.
Les J.O. modernes ont été annulés trois fois au
XXème siècle pour cause de guerre mondiale.
Mais pour une pandémie,
ça ne s'est jamais produit.
Ça aurait été une première
dont on est content de se passer,
à l'inverse des autres nouveautés
qui ont façonné toute l'histoire des Jeux.
Allez, suivez moi, je vais vous raconter tout ça.
Ça va être sportif.
Les Jeux olympiques ne datent pas d'hier.
Les premiers remontent à l'Antiquité,
ils se seraient tenus pour la première fois
il y a 2797 ans à Olympie, en Grèce.
Où ils auront ensuite lieu tous les quatre ans
jusqu'au 4ème siècle environ,
avant de disparaître.
En 1896, sous l'impulsion
du Français Pierre de Coubertin,
de nouveaux jeux sont lancés.
Ils se déroulent à Athènes.
Premiere nouveauté qui saute aux yeux
par rapport à l'antique édition :
les athlètes sont vêtus alors
que durant l'Antiquité, ils étaient nus.
Les sportifs devaient alors attacher leur sexe
avec une corde autour de leur taille
pour ne pas être gênés
dans leurs mouvements.
Bon, je ne vous fais pas de démo.
Cette nudité était en fait un moyen
de s'assurer qu'aucune femme
ne participait aux Jeux en se faisant
passer pour un homme.
Eh oui, à l'époque,
les J.O n'étaient pas mixtes
et ils ne l'étaient
pas non plus en 1896,
lors de la première édition
des Jeux olympiques modernes.
La nouveauté de ce côté-là
est intervenue en 1900 à Paris.
Les femmes peuvent alors se qualifier,
notamment au golf et au tennis.
Aujourd'hui, les femmes sont presque
aussi nombreuses que les hommes aux Jeux olympiques.
Aux J.O de Tokyo,. il y aura même
18 épreuves mixtes.
Heureusement, ça aurait été dommage.
Ça aurait fait vieux jeu.
Autre nouveauté lors de ces nouveaux
Jeux olympiques modernes de 1896 :
les disciplines.
Comme dans les Jeux antiques,
on trouve des épreuves de courses et de lancer.
Mais on innove en créant
une épreuve de toutes pièces : le marathon.
Contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait penser,
il est très récent.
Cette épreuve a été inventée en hommage
à un exploit réalisé 2400 ans plus tôt.
Un messager grec aurait couru
les 42 kilomètres qui séparent
la plage de Marathon
de la cité d'Athènes.
Clin d'œil de l'histoire, en 1896,
le premier vainqueur de la course
est un berger grec qui achève le marathon
en un peu moins de trois heures.
Si le marathon est toujours
une épreuve olympique,
d'autres disciplines
n'ont pas connu la même longévité.
C'est le cas du tir au pigeon vivant.
Devenu discipline olympique en 1900 et qui,
heureusement pour les pigeons,
a depuis disparu.
Cette même année, une épreuve
de 200 mètres natation
avec parcours d'obstacles
est également organisée.
Les nageurs doivent passer sous
des bateaux qui flottent sur la Seine.
Là encore, l'innovation ne fait pas long feu.
En fait, aujourd'hui, le pays qui accueille
les Jeux a la possibilité de proposer
jusqu'à cinq nouvelles disciplines,
en plus des 28 choisis par le Comité international olympique.
Du coup, cette année aux Jeux de Tokyo,
le karaté, le surf,
le skateboard ou encore l'escalade
deviennent pour la première fois des sports olympiques.
Avec un tel choix, Il y a vraiment
de quoi se prendre au jeu.
Allez encore quelques chiffres,
d'une petite dizaine de sports
et une quarantaine d'épreuves en 1896.
On est passé en 2021
à 33 sports et 339 épreuves.
Autre nouveauté introduite
au cours du XXème siècle :
les J.O. d'Hiver.
La première édition est créée
en 1924 à Chamonix.
Jusqu'en 1992, ils ont lieu
la même année que les J.O. d'Été.
Ensuite, ils sont décalés de deux ans
pour que les J.O. d'été et d'hiver soient intercalés.
Autre évolution marquante : le 29 juin 1948.
Lors des Jeux d'été qui se déroulent à Londres,
la première compétition de tir à l'arc
pour les athlètes en fauteuil roulant est organisée.
Elle sera à l'origine des Jeux paralympiques,
dont la première édition
se déroule à Rome en 1960.
Une compétition qui rassemble
400 sportifs issus de 23 pays.
Depuis, les Jeux paralympiques
ont lieu eux aussi tous les quatre ans.
La dernière déclinaison en date : les J.O. de la jeunesse, appelés "Les J.O.J.",
qui rassemblent des athlètes
ayant entre 15 et 18 ans.
C'est un véritable laboratoire
pour tester de nouveaux sports.
Des équipes mixtes hommes femmes sur les relais
d'athlétisme ou de natation, par exemple,
ou encore des équipes transnationales
avec des athlètes tirés au sort
et rassemblées sous une couleur
et non plus sous un drapeau.
Ils ont eu lieu pour la première fois
en 2010 pour ceux d'été et en 2012 pour ceux d'hiver.
Si je résume, tous les deux ans
se tiennent une version d'été
ou d'hiver des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques
ainsi que des Jeux olympiques de la jeunesse,
d'hiver ou d'été.
Eh bien, c'est du sport pour s'y retrouver.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Les athlètes eux mêmes ont innové à l'occasion des J.O.
Je vais vous montrer.
L'exemple le plus connu, c'est celui de Dick Fosbury,
premier athlète à utiliser la technique du rouleau dorsal
en saut en hauteur, baptisée depuis Fosbury.
C'était lors des J.O. De Mexico, en 1968.
Il remporte le titre grâce à cette technique
est depuis tous les athlètes de la discipline l'ont adoptée.
C'est aussi lors de ces Jeux que l'Américain
Jim HInes court le 100 mètres en moins de dix secondes,
ouvrant la voie aux stars de la discipline
comme Carl Lewis ou Usain Bolt.
C'est sur ce fameux 100 mètres
que les Américains avaient innové dès 1896.
Leurs athlètes avaient pris le départ
de la course les mains au sol,
alors que durant l'Antiquité, les Grecs
partaient debout comme sur cette amphore.
T'es un peu long, hein,
va falloir t'entraîner.
Ton chronomètre aussi. C'est grâce aux J.O.
Le premier chronomètre à quartz
est mis au point en 1964 pour les JO de Tokyo…
et conduit 5 ans plus tard, à la mise sur le marché
de la première montre à quartz .
En taekwondo, aux JO de 2012,
des capteurs sont installés
dans le casque de protection
des combattants
pour mesurer l’impact des frappes
de l’adversaire et compter les points.
A Rio, en 2016, un système
de détection électronique
en tir à l’arc sert à identifie
l’emplacement exact de la flèche sur la cible
à 0,2 millimètre près.
Et des écrans sont installés
au fond de la piscine pour indiquer
aux nageurs le nombre
de longueurs déjà effectuées.
Ça va ?
J'suis dans les temps ?
Bof.
Aux JO de Tokyo cette année, ce sont les robots
qui sont mis à l’honneur :
certains serviront de mascottes, d’autres faciliteront
les déplacements des personnes handicapées
et d’autres encore devraient
assister le personnel
pour aller récupérer
les javelots ou marteaux
sur les pelouses du stade
pendant les compétitions.
Désolé, mon grand,
t'as pas été sélectionné.
Les spectateurs ne sont pas oubliés.
Le premier direct radiophonique est mis en place
pour le marathon des JO de Paris,
grâce à des postes radio émetteurs
disposés par l’armée tout le long du parcours
Et en 1964, les JO,
qui se déroulent déjà à Tokyo,
sont retransmis pour la première fois
en direct dans le monde entier
grâce à une liaison satellite.
Les Jeux seront ainsi
de plus en plus suivis.
Tenez, en 2012, pour les JO de Londres,
4,8 milliards de personnes
assistent au spectacle olympique,
les épreuves et les cérémonies,
qui peuvent suivre grâce à près d'un millier
de caméras et 4000 micros.
Bon, quand est-ce que tu comptes
nous allumer le feu ?
J'y viens !
Contrairement à ce que l'on imagine,
la flamme est un rituel récent.
Elle a été utilisée pour la première fois
en 1936 aux JO De Berlin.
De Berlin, pour une raison
qui donne froid dans le dos.
Elle était censée représenter le feu sacré Aryen
qu'Hitler voulait étendre sur toute l'Europe.
Tout cela, évidemment,
c'est de l'histoire ancienne.
Les symboles ont changé.
La flamme existe toujours.
Tous les quatre ans, elle est allumée
sur les ruines du temple d'Héra.
Là où les Grecs de l'Antiquité allumaient
déjà des feux lors des anciens JO.
Puis elle est transportée jusqu'à la ville d'accueil,
le plus souvent par des coureurs.
Mais là aussi,
les JO ont parfois innové :
La flamme a voyagé en bateau,
à ski, en motoneige,
porté par un nageur au dessus de l'eau,
par un plongeur sous l'eau,
en parachute, à cheval, à dos de chameau
et même en concorde.
Attention, c'est bientôt
la cérémonie d'ouverture.
C’est ça avec tout le tintouin…
défilé des athlètes, discours, hymne olympique,
levée du drapeau olympique.
Avant, il y avait même
un lâcher de colombes.
Et pourquoi il y a plus de colombes?
Ça sent le roussi cette histoire.
C'est ça le problème,
c'est qu'après leur envol,
des oiseaux venaient régulièrement
se poser sur le bord de la vasque,
juste avant l'arrivée de la flamme
olympique et de l'allumage.
Vous imaginez la suite.
Du coup, plus de colombes depuis 1988.
Autre nouveauté protocolaire,
très récente celle-ci,
le slogan des JO va lui aussi changer.
Jusqu'à présent, c'était celui choisi
par Pierre de Coubertin.
"Plus vite, plus haut, plus fort."
Le CIO, le Comité international olympique,
a décidé d'ajouter le mot : "ensemble".
"Plus vite, plus haut, plus fort ensemble."
Une façon de dire que les Jeux ne sont
pas uniquement une question de performance,
mais qu'ils doivent rassembler le monde.
Enfin, dernière évolution à mentionner les médailles.
Une histoire de revers.
Depuis 1928, la plupart représentaient
en effet sur l’une de leur face
la déesse de la victoire, tenant d'une main
des lauriers, de l'autre, une palme
devant le Colisée.
Un monument romain.
Depuis 2004, l'erreur est rectifiée.
La déesse, tenant toujours une palme,
se tient désormais à l'intérieur du stade
panathénaïque d’Athènes,
celui là même qui avait été rénové
pour accueillir les JO de 1896.
Il faut bien rendre à César ce qui ...
Non justement rendre à la Grèce
ce qui appartient à la Grèce.
Et puis, toujours à propos de médailles, sachez que
les 5000 qui seront distribués cette année à Tokyo
ont été fabriqués à partir de métaux issus
du recyclage de petits appareils électroniques
des smartphones, par exemple.
Ils ont été collectés entre 2017
et 2019 à travers tout le Japon.
Ça, c'est un beau message,
un peu téléphoné, mais ça vaut une médaille.
C'est vrai.
Allez les champions, on se retrouve très vite,
c'est le cas de le dire,
dans un prochain chez Jamy
et en attendant, n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas à m'indiquait
en commentaire
l'épreuve qui vous fait le plus frissonner
et vos champions préférés.